des immeubles en ruines
et des sirènes qui sonne à longueur de
journée akram à tort ce que dans l'est
de l'ukraine la pression est chaque jour
un peu plus forte ici plus de trois
quarts des habitants fuient la ville il
serait encore 45 milles sur place des
civils qui doivent faire face
continuellement aux bombardements russes
c'est vraiment très compliqué il ya des
musiques toute la journée regardez nous
entendons les sirènes
il y a des sirènes tout le temps
la guerre est en pleine rue
cram à tort ce qu est une ville
stratégique et actuellement une des
cibles majeures des forces russes c'est
ici même il ya trois semaines qu'un
missile avait frappé la gare remplis de
civils qui tentaient de fuir près de 60
personnes avaient trouvé la mort dans
l'hôpital de la ville le souvenir de
cette journée est encore très douloureux
ici le personnel hospitalier doit faire
face au manque de soignants seuls trois
chirurgiens sont restés ils savent que
la situation s'annonce critique
les habitants qui sont encore dans la
ville savent que si nous partons il n'y
aura vraiment plus personne pour les
soigner et un grand nombre de civils
mourra sans ce soutien médical
selon les autorités locales les forces
russes seraient désormais à moins de 50
kilomètres de cramât torse